you know what grumpy old pants over here
grumpy pants chin is a little grumpy
he's saying because we go what's going
on Saturday pants knee goes I'm pissed
off right this thing goes I'm just
kidding
smiling his highs not your fates are
smiling your eyes are tears
she's got Korean hun energy don't [ __ ]
what's white white in a bad mood since
I'm not working internet slower some
[ __ ] no I don't know I guess I am in a
mood are you in it some days you wake up
like that sometimes I have to you know
what though did you sometimes you wake
up me like [ __ ] did you hear that
thunder my son mean him we're playing
baseball in the backyard and he freaked
the [ __ ] out yeah I said listen my buddy
that's God bowling he's like no I'm not
buying it that was terrible why yeah
well my wife my wife loves thunder she
goes whoo whoo whoo thunder and she
grabbed the kids because we're not doing
anything today we're not doing anything
today I want like candles and get into a
warm blanket oh my god it's a middle of
a sunburn a wife my wife had a little
health scare my wife was she's not like
me she's not she's not she's tough she
has she's vulnerable she couldn't move
her eyeballs when she would turn her
eyeballs left or right okay like total
pain and it went on for three days
it went on for three days and she
finally went on you know what you don't
do is you don't go on when you tee yeah
in Wikipedia because without a doubt
without a doubt look at it it's the
worst of the worst day you'll think you
have AIDS but the one thing you do know
that when you have that pressure behind
your eyeballs is you have quoi coma you
had there are five different well comas
and it can't be anything else oh my god
coma and I went what she goes I have to
go to the eye doctor right now so I go
all right she's done all the research
very calm very cool my doctor goes no
you don't but what you do have is
scratch scratched up eyeballs scratch
right yes and and and said my wife said
but that doesn't make sense and the eye
doctor goes it's from the ends do you
have horses and she goes I do because do
you push your face against the horse and
now the horse which my wife died I could
be tough the whole wife Miwako bad word
scratches our eyes first of all
first of all I believe in my heart that
my wife has said sexual trans I knew it
- I get that vibe from her - it's a
1,200 pound reality it's a proton now
it's it's it's what is rock larger Evan
the ebony black the most shiny beautiful
black beautiful power muscle power yeah
a dick on him - hold on energy sounds
like now just hear me out here she likes
big come on around careful
big dick hey kitty energy animal take it
easy
yeah no I'm just saying she likes big
okay Rousey this thing is black stylish
okay funny she does have he does spotted
dick animal he does have he does have
beautiful new shoes he just got he just
got shoot up dude he's got a beautiful
saddle on him an abraded bridle I'm not
a detaching your big old horse thighs
bro why your hand was dressing in that
one he I feel like you know you won't
know you won't meet any guys her that
into horses now like I feel like it
wealthy single women who were like super
laws yeah if you if you have a
girlfriend or you have a friend who's a
girl she's constantly posting pictures
of that with like horses or dogs all the
time like they're there cannot yeah
you cannot yell from a rooftop any
louder that you're single as the horse
does take over for the boyfriend the
husband but also the men in the
horseback riding scene not they're not
polo but the men they tend to be they
tend to be what's the word I'm gonna go
yeah yeah anyways a little too much time
around the horsey
we got equestrian male equestrian
champions there they're all buried there
but but um my wife my wife was was was
the slaw was brushing her horse I was at
the stables she was brushing him and she
went like this she goes there
she buried his her nose in right behind
his shoulder and she went she goes I
know I get I'm allergic but it's worth
it oh yeah she comes home and her eyes
are all red oh she's the cat correct and
she and shadow [ __ ] with it still [ __ ]
with it that's how that's how attractive
do you want whenever we talk about
horses and I know some people hate it
when I bring I cannot get over that mr.
hands video well that guys [ __ ] that
horse yeah or the whole I'm sorry the
guys the horse is [ __ ] the guy and he
just goes guts deep and can't watch it I
can't it just explodes in his ass yeah I
can't watch it is a Wednesday morning
and we're kicking off like this but
still there's some red flags with horses
there are some red flags can you still
go to Tijuana watch those donkey shows
with the girls or is that kind of sound
upon I think so the words out you don't
know that you know ho I didn't know
about mr. hands on how you found that I
do me a favor just do yourself a favor
and just Google mr. hands video for me
so you can refresh Brian eyes memory can
you do that important really I promise
you won't give me no it's not like I
promise you that I'll buy your new
computer and [ __ ] on there or you send
to Jay Chou I'll take care of all of it
yeah let me go to uh go to mr. hands bro
deal now that I like it let me have some
chin like Cinnabon no you don't like
Cinnabon I never go to Cinnabon have you
ever had the icing on Cinnabon I've had
I'm sure you like to enjoy the icing
that's all what's going on here not that
much well if you enjoy icing she's who
that who brought the good news [ __ ]
cream well is a caveat on horseback
riding in men dude the most dangerous
sport in the world is event click on
that wolf the first video this is long
but bro it's you too bro it's not
YouTube oh no its male and this looks
terrible already what do I tell it's a
bet it's it's at the high school listen
it's not 4k you know it's on avatar 3
watching it's not Abbot our 3d loud Zeta
mo betta production presents deep
thrusts sorry mister I've heard of that
mr. hands okay he's mr. right actor
horse or mr. hands will be the [ __ ]
Dodd chin just take this brush backwards
too
there were alright another button no no
he's honest he's a
now yeah is it come on dude absolutely
no yeah you're missing the best part
because the horse don't know Gator don't
play the horse trying to get his rocks
off you don't know how deep to go oh I
can't that's not yeah that'll kill you
the German died died like a gentleman
died yeah a gentleman died I was from
covering my face I've never seen that
horrifying I've actually never seen that
I've always said oh yeah yeah yeah I
can't watch my hands are still over I
hate herbal oh my lord
just a little bit of a - and it was
freaking horrified well you know this
must be what happens that's not uncommon
I guess he's been doing that for quite
some time sneak into her horns and
getting dealt with in the booty hole
apparently as a partner in crime was
like let me just direct speak Hokkien I
was gonna say you let that's dangerous
you have that horses you know boy
absolute super dance because you know
horse trying to bust nuts bro and then
and then he don't know how deep to go
and then of course that horse is like I
mean kill them chin died man died
shortly after he really died yeah oh
yeah I mean that I do famous before you
I'm not some sort of sick I'm not watch
out see how I wouldn't find out about
that unless he died you see how big that
I'm wanna I can do bigger than my own it
was an arm sighs yeah yeah you got to
know that that's like his you gotta know
he's been doing it he's been [ __ ] by
horses
but that horse just simple Matt that
deep rusty that's that big dick energy
bro
it's simple math that's big dick energy
at its finest bro yeah yeah you would
[ __ ] delete it with your big dick
energy last night you're infuriating
shirts get a couple lazy lazy [ __ ]
hallway hangers them [ __ ] boys hallway
hangers just hanging around unbelievable
it's
yes though you've never seen this video
not with Drake and Will Ferrel now
because this Toronto Raptors player just
got traded
yeah and they did this video and it's a
video mocking him gain trade and he got
trade names a star player look and he
does he will play this he's already
watch how good watch how good Drake is
your handshake sucks we will trade you
absolutely that's for David that's the
guy you get really
this is talking mark mouth over smart
mouth what's your name
Tamar Tamar Tamar Tamar Tamar I've said
the less I like it
this is why we're here yeah I think I
think we just got a demonstrator yeah I
want to take notes this first one's
called the Jenga Jenga all right next up
coach I think we're going gossip queen
ready the fans can see this rate to nyet
gossip gossip Queen this is one of our
more sophisticated ones the prom fans
maintain a nice firm grip on the hips
and how great is Drake well you grew up
an actor right
starting today but the reason why this
is great I love in everything because
we'll a Will Ferrell's birthday but also
that rose in for the Toronto Raptors was
there literally their star player got
traded for a Kwame Leonard play might
play my video
I got no problems tell me well then the
foliage in case the [ __ ] hits the fan
your disappearance I'm talking about
your career anything better than when
all of a certain thing comes back it's
the best there's no I left that's the by
far the best it was good to me T City
last night yeah and I thought to myself
like we were talking about New York you
were talking about fighting and you guys
were having a real in-depth sort of in
the know conversation about you know
training and sparring and strategy and
ideas but I thought to myself was
looking at you and I was like I was like
you're now a comic and they're watching
you and you're in these lineups and I
was like it was just so interesting
because I was like I looked he I was
like how far we've all come I know like
I like that I was like that would have
been you would have been a retired or
trying to get your next fight and I do I
was like god I've been super depressed I
and I knew he would have been in the
audience watching know just like yeah I
guess I watch Brian watch this part and
then exactly not for me this not for me
in this lifetime yeah t city was on the
TV show below about yesterday and him
and his coach they were just saying how
you know they're a little down brother
or Tate or the max hallway fight falling
out and all that stuff and he's like all
I've been to I'm like heavy Gotti like a
get away have you got a break that's not
really much been training trying to stay
ready like you take some time off man
you relax he's a cat I [ __ ] need to
the coach like what are you doing
tonight I was a guy have to stand up
like actually guys should come it's
literally Tuesday nights is the best
night of comedy in America yep Tuesday
nights in college it's by far the night
have taught me I want I'm on this
amazing lab you guys should come you got
Marc Maron you got crystal yeah yeah TJ
Miller
TJ Marc Maron you Sam Triple E cake wigs
I mean you just got great people
murderers row man yeah yeah
and so they came they had a great time
yeah great great time but how fun is
that
either look or that kid Brian good
be blue eyes a deep blue eye how about
so yesterday he's big for a 45 hour man
look around another 45 hours yeah he's
tall though he's taller he still well
hit him in the mats are very similar max
might even be taught bigger
I heard Max's six foot that's bigger
than he is which is that's why the bolt
fight at 55 but eventually but I was
saying with with Brian yesterday I'm on
the show I'm below the belt so we do our
normal interview time on the max Holly
the fall I went down was gonna do and
all that normal sit-down interview but
then he posted a video on Instagram of
him jump kick in a water bottle off his
buddy's head who's kind of tall so we
did play this game called candy kick it
and you know that song yes I can
so we haven't kicked different things
like a water balloon
like waist-high kicked the [ __ ] out of
got him on wet cake is good you could do
that and then I held this I held this
like thing of died he like brown house
that and but I'm holding it like this
high and then last when I put a cup of
jell-o on my head and he does a jumping
crane kick and [ __ ] kicks off almost
were you standing up standing let me see
it comes out it comes out I think
tomorrow morning dancers but it's well
it's offensive he's a hell of an athlete
I mean you you've trained with him for
years right yeah he's a freak great
great it does have those blue eyes huh
deep keep him away from his girl was
keep him away from your girl cuz he'll
beat you up and take your girl good guy
man great minutes coach great okay yeah
always want me to surf but the they go
to like these crazy spots I'm like I
don't wanna die no he was yeah first
time I went man and he goes like this
Wow like oh you got the wave and he goes
no no I drowned that to recess and I go
dude why would you ask me go in the
toilet so he goes you're not gonna die
do you know what they're doing i oh no
no i go in that's the same i'm not going
get lost see does he give a [ __ ] where
is he watch this where is the ira he
went down right here don't go in there
where is it i don't you're dead ready
you got about a minute you got about a
working minute there's no time you know
how you lose your keys you're in the
ocean you're much smaller than keys in a
room wait clip wave where is he
he's in the sea somewhere that's not
gonna happen but I was getting nervous
listening to him talk about sparring at
wild-card like just the kind of dudes
that he gets in with which are pro
boxers high-level Pro boxers and you
said so I would think if you're an MMA
guy that the high-level Pro boxers are
just gonna move around with you because
that's their game and you were like no
no no they want to make it exist they're
gonna punch the wild card they're gonna
try and knock yo you got a bounty in
your head when you walk in there I've
been there yeah been there done so when
you are he likes that stuff he's like I
like it for the nerves look at his kids
Lia's son bottom left there yeah
gorgeous this is a brother I think he
has a little brother too yeah he has a
five year old and a six year old oh wow
I did not yeah here's a little brother
yeah okay I'm just making diamond pieces
references out it's a reference yeah you
were talking about Brian Ortega
obviously yes well I'm just saying
they're parents but do cells on there
yeah yeah seizing up again just like my
pins you got it you got a mouth on you
so there's my brother I don't think Jay
got that mouth pity Jay has some thick
lips or juice y'all nothing I don't know
about that Jason Fisher does the last
thing I can see Jay doing is gonna dog
because you have deer cells it means you
have some thick lips bro he's got sure
he goes Jays got some yeah he does he's
little on shoulders for days look at him
look at Jay look at that guy look at
David Blaine with a lot of weight I
can't believe is like in Chicago man hey
Jay bothers me I really would love him I
want him to be there he doesn't post
much huh
Jesus Christ he goes from racecars and
then his last post service it's a
blended year ago that's for everyone
though he's not Instagram no he just
went public it was private cuz his work
complain because you know we call him
big dick bandit and grand hog oh so you
guys do I did go to private because
people at work like hey on your social
media beavers
about your penis and the reference in
your DSL connection his office he went
by like grand Hong Kong so he's that
he's all please stop dude dude let me
see it a liability liability of being
associated with fighter in decayed so he
went private forever but then I told her
one to wish him happy birthday is I just
got too many requests so I said go back
to public so Jay sobs public now y'all
that's that's hilarious so funny we do
talk about him a lot yeah
grant Hawk go so grant up me really
grand hugger well I had like sometimes a
woman that copy be it that the psoriasis
you know the woman does light therapy
and she's like I love podcasts and I go
oh I have a podcast what is it called
she writes it out half the listener like
no no no you that's not for you ma'am
ma'am no not for you not for you it's
two guys talking about dicks oh but I
was worse I was getting coffee today and
the guys like like you know whatever I
walk in I can see him like looking at me
and then the guy goes you're you hearin
job writing like yeah what's up man this
might copy spot Alfred's coffee off
Montana yeah and now I guess my SWAT man
he's a cool cool man he's a glass stand
up now right this ring goes I don't I
don't know he goes yeah yeah he does
that
here's a podcast we talk about dicks and
stuff the fighter what is it I will stop
probably about take so you know it's
like we make dick jokes and we've talked
about a lot of weird no father my father
three guys who bunch of guys I finally I
try to listen to this other one yeah I
can't get to you I had a email from a
guy on a military base and he's like
dude don't ever stop with the dick talk
because cuz me my bros were stationed in
I forget where somewhere remote and he
goes that's why how we act we're all
here that's all we do mail each other's
together that's what this is we talk
that's what this is well last night when
I'm 51 years old and Chris and we're in
there TJ Mel is there anybody and Chris
is teaching self defense and we're doing
the same thing where I'm attacking
joking and falling what do you mean and
and I kept charging him and he was
throwing I fall into the wall and stuff
like that
and he just looked at me and I was on
the ground like that I was a god you're
amazing and he looks at me he goes
you're 51 I know I know dude how fired
up like when you you and Chris came in
they were just announced we go on stage
and I [ __ ] thrust my god I realize
how hard it but Danny Frank I he's a CIA
agent I fell into him he's a small guy
and Brennan just bumped me chest by me
and I flew off the the three gold later
[ __ ] and then agent chefs bump Brian
and you just go wow too soon Christmas
rash and then Mark Brandon goes enough
your alpha energy nothing out there
grows out of energy in that room I gotta
get it get it get it away from me I'm so
fond um I got a show tonight and we
should get do it man where Theo and I
have a show at The Comedy Store in the
Billy room I'm doing the Venice
underground I know we should Courtney
cause I should have done I open up
there's two reefers usually Friday I
could use you but what time is it at
10:00 my shows at 10:00 fool you go on
at 10:00 no when do you go on bro what's
my show
huh it's my show so I'll break going a
little later huh yeah you could come
down I'll kick him down and do a quick
let's see I'll call I'll see what's up
so I can get you in and out what's your
show yeah it's gonna be fun I get you
have to do that room can't believe you
haven't done that room yeah we have
might be your fitting
it may turn into your favorite room one
of the common story you'll love it um
there was this so rare that night one
that I did I performed in front of six
people at the house and then there was
this there's just so there's a show gone
in the other room there's three people
in that room but then there was comics
going up and I was like oh let's see and
see how these other comics up and this
guy marked a bonus I think that's his
name marked a bonus goes up there and he
he's young videos I know I look like a
politician
and he looks identical to one and just
started going it go there is like you
he's young
young and Irene goes I know I look like
a politician you guys hate me right now
but he did a set and [ __ ] crushed it
for these like right here to seven
people and he was so funny man so so I
mean I'm in and then the Icehouse lady
goes yeah well you know we're looking
for more comics here and that's why we
do these shows I'm like that guy I don't
know who he is but you guys you guys
should be booking that guy like I
watched a ton of comedy I'm telling you
that guy can [ __ ] do this
and I go to him I go hey man how long
you been doing this I think he said like
10 years he's from Canada
he just moved here Indians yeah Jim
Carrey I mean the Charmin Canadian I
mean there's goes on I just said Jim
Carrey but so anyways he got does stink
rushes I tell Isis BAM they start
booking him then I reached out to him
last week he's like dude I got a show at
The Comedy Store and he's doing a set
there tonight he's never done a show at
The Comedy Store really he's a monster
good for him I'm sure ten years in
Canada the bonus you're gonna be funny
and look at him though yeah gray hair
probably 30 that's what happens he looks
young and older at the same time yeah
the hair really throws you off some
people just look older age yeah this
looks so yeah he plays with it - it's
funny that's really cool yeah should be
good should be fun tonight do that he
mean hey hey dude I hate to bring this
up on air but uh who should I send the
bill to for open up for you Thursday
Friday what what are you talking about
what bill well oh you don't think I'm
doing this for free why do you charge
for your comedy services wha look I'm
putting you up in a hotel a hotel pay me
what a man for what bro
I [ __ ] love Kay I had a good set last
night
like I never do I know I had a good set
last night and I look at Chris get to
follow me a good luck mom enjoy that you
know Chris shoots a special next week I
didn't know her Netflix
really I don't even where you didn't
talk about it where I forget good friend
he was all that place for Michael that
place he hasn't make sense it's buddy I
haven't seen him dude he has a new
closer that he's doing for the special
he did last night I love that airplane
bit not the airplane one here's a new
one
he's a cow oh my god brought that
[ __ ] place down that's killer
here's a day we're closed I go I
definitely would closes oh yeah yeah
Chris is so fun got a crystal clear
sense of humor in the word oh you know
how it came out that Netflix is
green-lighting 60 specials sorry Chris
about it cuz his speche was on there and
he goes no he is that's the way that
headline it makes it seem like it's you
know like everyone's getting specials
but the thing Wow let's not look like
that Chris hey Chris are you doing magic
realm what's up yeah cuz you do magic
I'm sorry are you in [ __ ] train
are you brand trained man you are you
Canadian guitarist what are you doing
dude what the [ __ ] he's Miller Band from
the 1970s Christ look at him oh wow
wait wait a smolder on are you you look
like the lead singer of a cover band for
Nickelback look at that fun those 60
specials yeah that's that's miss kind of
construing because what's going on there
is it 60 specials but there's like it's
in gonna be in Chinese Japanese
Portuguese South Africa it's all it's
all it's not just it's not 60 English
American comics
see what Chris has to say but watch how
I answer the phone in a noxious way
let's see look at that face the
countdown this one oh my god
his face what is that stupid picture
that's that's so gross
look at him look at that with his
pervert
oh well and you know what I do when I
call him I'll get a text as I'm calling
him and it'll say nah
oh yeah he's ridiculous yeah shoot a
special shooting a special no idea chin
are you excited about Chicago of course
dude what's going on with you man what
happened I'm kicked in the nuts just a
girl out and shut you down or something
yeah
you know weird vibe from chin are you be
ah no he's I'm good he's good I like his
outfit today
no he's full of [ __ ] you're letting off
the hook man I don't chin I've been on
the road can smell a time would I tell
you what's going on right now mr. hands
video no let me say a video get you down
huh it bought me my kick you like garage
back honest kratom know what oh you'll
see that how did you know cuz I know you
really should know every day say about
every single day oh I'll get off it when
I want very treatment you don't feel the
need to increase the dosage
I don't yeah it's wild you take tooth I
take it just like a regular supplement
I've been taking alpha brain too so
maybe that's your mixing them do you
feel like me you in solve what kind of
supplements you take no problems well
the ID on from on it sent over some like
a care package so I've been taking that
pirate tech thingy thanks for your time
the immune system immune system there
you go that and then alpha brain huh
yeah that biotech I honestly I think I'm
just tired I think this is the first
time I've been actually really tired you
don't drink the time for anything yeah
I'm usually not that time you're not
drink coffee I drink instant coffee and
I don't know an instant coffee with all
the great coffee out there I don't
instant coffee because it's fast do you
take a mallet and bash your balls in the
morning while you drink it what
Coffee this is the katadyn think on this
stuff like my mother an instant coffee I
go I really take don't I'd rather you
pour hot water my bowl and then she
never calls it a chance because you know
you should are you gonna get a sunburn
before you go what what would a suntan
you've been alive for 70 well she's kind
of right because it is damaging say Sun
but say suntan say something yeah and
also don't tell me what I'm taking
propecia don't say in all seriousness go
just wear a wig don't say that I'm with
you I've been saying this for years a
wig
walk around you know why because I would
rip it off from time - yeah that's right
a wig I told you that this is the guy
laughing Mike acting school really good
actor really cool looking guy and had a
bald head an intense deep voice and kind
of ran things and he was a [ __ ] great
actor and one day he wasn't working
wasn't getting jobs and we had something
on in our class called terrorist theater
and the teacher would say how you doing
man come over here for a sec a great job
you do a great scene great job man very
talented what was the last time you
worked well I did this thing no no when
was the last time you got paid to be an
actor um what do you mean um what does
that mean she's well know I was then I
need an answer well may I did a thing
what did you get paid I mean the last
time I got paid wasn't so it's been a
year and a half but been a year to have
any looking to go
you're on terrorist theater you know
what that means you got I believe it was
three or six weeks to book a paying gig
and prove it in Hollywood or you know
you're out of the class forever
it's called terrorist theater where are
you well you got to just cuz like we're
holding you hostage you're out of the
club is before 9/11 your have see we're
towards you're out of the class forever
yeah and people know about forever even
booked jobs that they go okay and they
get on it tambour and jeffrey tambor
what do you mean okay what is okay mean
I don't even know what that means I know
I can't teach it so
okay can you [ __ ] with use you can just
stay there in the that routine or just
doing this so like hopefully something
happened so he puts himself he gets on
Terrace theater and here he shows up at
Monday
I'm not kidding the men was Will Ferrell
he had a he had a full head of hair it
was it was a we've you know how would
you Brian can weave it in Ryan Urlacher
Brian they're like yeah yet yet the
transplant no he didn't he had a weave
he had something go on my scalp bring up
we it's a type of wig Brian see it's the
first thing Brian this was so obviously
awake this was so obvious before an
average Oh first of all I have no idea
what he thinks he's doing because I love
him wished I love them bald okay he's
actually great bald a great bald head
great well he looks good with hair
though I remember I was working for Fox
the time he came in the avocado room and
he had here and I was like what are you
doing what are you doing the [ __ ] it
looks so good without her yeah he looks
way better without God he's a good
football player he sure was but what did
look he decides and stuff how'd that
growing well he probably had a side so
you get this weird weave on top and
that's what this guy had but it was so
much worse than that it was so loud it
was oily thick and nylon and he goes
like this and he sat me netiquette can't
talk to you like hey so I want to get
some advice on the business they typed
you type in uh what procedure did Brian
Urlacher have first here let's see what
exactly keep going be sorry he just goes
I'm trying to shave my deal up a little
bit because I want to play like leading
man and not villain so much I was like
well you're not going to this is
ridiculous see he had a transplant now
that that's a site go back no this is
what he did mmm we saw is all marketing
yeah that's all mark and that's their
site if you go back like do a real
article don't do a campaign but he did
it there that's why I'm saying yeah I
know but you were not gonna get you know
an article for it right about their
shoes Florida here transplant
well there you go retired bears like we
are seeking at least toner damages from
Florida here resident restoration coming
he alleges his name and image without
his permission
there you go Oh her like her surprised
fans in 2016 when the formerly bald
bears showed off a full head of hair he
probably got a hair track
you can see he's got hair but I don't
know that looks like a lot of hair as a
guys had one it's really hard to do that
so the grown popular the folic your unit
extraction also known as fue hair
transplant Wow you don't need it you
don't need it
dude do it bro got it but I mean it
looked pretty [ __ ] good though yeah
it does
looks real Jinyu not losing your hair
are you it's thinning for sure is it
yeah we're at like everywhere especially
all that top about to go bro
well I mean super super like shape
though but it's thinning for sure are
you worried about it if it goes it goes
I feel like you have a good bald head
you look like a villain and big trouble
a little China be bothered with about it
you look over the bald head no I was
very strange you need to go you have a
bald head I mean when you when a shochet
yeah like bald and shades different
shade looks good on you I think I don't
know why you don't do that do you get
don't you get tired of your hair and
having it no how do you talk about what
do you what am i trying to look like a
meat head that's like a meat head right
no I love my hair man you kidding me
well yeah disco
oh I know it's gone
ah you got a whole different whole set
of here you make you look like [ __ ] you
want me to shave it no I don't you take
it off don't you get tired and you'll
see get rid of yours bro don't get tired
of having it all you don't you should do
you should just shave the top and leave
the Sun don't you don't get tired of
having I think you again let's do it
shut up silent feel silence 1,400
oh come over and break your studio boys
do who is that oh it's so it steals
guests
that's a guest yeah I don't know if
that's right that might be Will Sasso so
let's go see you guys take your break
real quick well I'm going to see who the
[ __ ] is over there you guys in the fresh
gear what fresh gear bang here like this
like that bro oh this oh this is five
four where that cost about 280 to help
you belong wrong without even close bro
at 5-4 click on the link in the bottom
you can get fresh gear like this your
jeans like this give me at new kicks or
Macy grant they're all whites they just
drop when we click at the link on the
bottom you sign up your first month is
50% off plus sign up plus sunglasses and
socks
damn man yeah this money doesn't cost
you much to look good in threads alright
that's how it goes ashin forward baby
you get the new gear fit your scent off
click at the link on the bottom five for
Grande see what else you want get hit
let's lay the smackdown on Theo bro yeah
we can all we've done for that man well
people don't really come from do what
I'm saying I hear you you know what I'm
saying I'm here and every every child is
gonna rebel against his parents but you
gotta slap him down that baby bird you
got a dump in his mouth still you got it
from your mouth yep and dump you feed
him more I'm yeah bro don't forget he's
still in the nest the Papa mama bird you
say next door he's still in the nest
yeah we'll shut your whole operation on
the Papa and your the mama bird and we
just tell you a baby bird uh well you
will take you will swallow what we give
you to swallow hold on let's go let's go
dude some kind of it that's cuz I just
saw something what do you got chin
alright the first one is about a serial
killer a guy that was caught a long time
line not a long time with me like few
months ago you missed the key point
though bro it was Anna and they found
maybe they found body parts in his like
planners
outside of his apartment area yeah would
they put like trees and stuff they found
body parts in there apparently cops have
been finding body parts around his
location every single day since they've
been searching his areas and potted
plants additional human remains almost
every day after resuming a search on the
property we did recruit recover human
remains virtually every day were there
Jesus I want to span from July 4th to
Friday
did he kill men what did yeah he was he
was like a gay yeah you like sitting on
his lap Wow he just got off on the act
of killing people remains of seven men
keep scrolling down the remains of seven
men Jesus why the victims have been
identified all dudes
aw dudes my age all dudes we can hook up
with a Santa MacArthur had some sort of
relationship with each of his victims
some which were sexual Wow you think
that they'd be like oh these guys are
all disappearing and who did you know
you think they'd buy kill mall Santa
Claus trying to [ __ ] probably hard pass
any mall Santa Claus and this goes out
for it all the listeners any mall Santa
Claus slides in your DMS you run yeah
you report it that's right that's right
don't trust him bro Easter bunnies -
what else yet you all right so Elon Musk
after he did that tweet about the
diver who he called the pedo investors
of Tesla demanded that he apologized are
there pull out mmm but so dose that was
yesterday
today he put out apology sweet enough to
that guy yep that's how it goes yeah we
all know that's not real though right
like when they really you know I'm
saying like you ease forced to do that
words were spoken in anger after mr.
Unsworth said several untruth and
suggested I engage in sexual act with
the mini-sub dive team leader justify my
actions against you know health is mine
and mine alone mr. Unsworth said several
untruths and suggested I engaged in
sexual acts with a minute she said I
know what he said he goes take that
mini-sub and stick it up your ass cuz I
know what I'm doing it I'm down here
what he said once you'll [ __ ] that
minute sir yeah probably
shove it up for sexual acts my words
over his head so funnies tweeted a
suggested sexual act with a min he's out
like for the best three I mean that's
really funny
alright I don't know much about baseball
but this guy Josh hater who's in MLB he
tweeted things out when he was younger
17 I think yeah 17 and it's caught up to
him now so we should have Twitter in the
age of 30
yeah and here are some of the tweets he
was it was very like homophobic and then
uh racist against black people
so you've 17 this one says suck my [ __ ]
I'll murder your family and goes then
put KKK then he put gay people freaked
me out this dude comes in with pony
shirts and a pony
Malbec gave you the [ __ ] has shaked the
[ __ ] they put wah ha now Who am I giving
I was a little ninja ninja
I hate gay people need a second I'm
kidding
you 17 ignorant yeah grow up
I don't know if like I wouldn't want
Twitter when I was 17 right and then as
you guys you grow up here you you you
mature and you realize you were ignorant
and you were an idiot and you by the way
you were a different person yeah I don't
think he's a bad person we all have the
potential you don't come better definite
don't do that right we all have that the
great thing is that we as people are
ever-changing the worst the the shitty
thing is people can just go back find
that if they're looking for dirt onion
then pays no I hope they don't find my
stuff when you're 17 when I was just
look at first hand written script it
right now look at the scroll we face or
my true this book it's our old guy
things just a phase
hopefully the sucking dick is just a
face because really I don't want it why
am i into dudes in that thirties play
mall Santas hopefully go to Hollywood
and find a sugar daddy mm-hmm my friend
is gay would always say that he'd be on
the plane and he'd talking to some
businessman could go looking guy and
finally he'd be like just so you know I
have a boyfriend and the guy looked at
him and goes yeah and just so you know
I'm married with three kids and so began
the affair for a long time whoa oh yeah
on a plane we suck each other off on the
well yeah but they went right to a hotel
after that or maybe on the plane maybe
my friend said when he was 15 he was hey
how can i with dudes in their 40s 50
lots of salt brother he was in the back
oh yeah this wasn't the 80s in the 80s
oh it's eighties you're good I know now
my buddy he's my age now buddy when he
was in the eighties he goes when I was
in high school he was a model for
Versace a really good-looking kid and he
said I would be in these work rail yeah
like mr. Han I pick up dudes use a young
mister he liked over the bins yeah damn
he would pick up dudes get rail yeah you
said he would go to the Broadway plays
he had money came from a lot of money go
to a Broadway play alone and there'd
always be some stud older dude and he
would hook up with him right there
that's what he liked
yep 15 16 17 for search and stuff wow
dude powerful men rich powerful men and
maybe wouldn't tell me who there was a
Republican senator and his wife and he
used to have sex when he was in his 20s
well I'm sorry let me back that up when
he was 18 19 20 it started when we were
in college
and I didn't know he was gay and then it
carried on for ten years after that he
would have sex with this Republican
senator and his wife and then oh yeah
and they would have they would have
these parties and he was kind of a main
event because he was like this stud
Versace model and yeah I bet he got paid
a hard cold cash I don't know he never
said that he just got yeah pay to have
sex yeah he's like this here's this
really famous Republican senator and his
Republican senator like what point are
you sitting there like this and the
Republican Center turned to him I mean
he had his wife in the chair and he goes
you're about your she's about to get
[ __ ] and my buddy was like okay well
you're gonna have sex with your wife
cool Jesus yeah all kinds of freaky [ __ ]
freaks gonna freak what else gets in
this is a crazy one a police shootout is
wild he saw the serious this is crazy so
there's two people that they thought was
suspected of killing someone at a car
wash and then the cops chased these guys
and the guy started shooting at the cop
so it was like 60 60 rounds like it
kills somebody at the car so they did
okay yeah these two guys killed somebody
why did we were coming I don't know but
let me see their faces first let me see
you know so one guy died this guy died
this guy didn't die all right let's did
but look how he walked look I shoots
through the windshield this is the top
shoes guys because they're firing at him
damn it guys flying
[Music]
dude being a cop is a a [ __ ] job and
are they in a SUV but they can't hit the
car son guys do whatever they can to get
away and how about you driving with one
arm yeah and feel like there should be a
better way to do that but
[Music]
the fans can see this video chin damn
how fast is it what close you he's
flying to the last word a little bit
yeah he's in a reason X we take an
explorer edition this guy's a badass to
watch this Jesus do what our guys think
of here I
you're never gonna shot Kate what'd you
say - ah - now who's firing the suspect
you're watching the best episode of cops
ever I know what the [ __ ] you look s
thinking firing at cops like that I mean
they killed someone they know they're
gonna they just want to go just on a
suicide mission yeah well I just think I
do
I'm on my edge of my seat
and did they stop and just start firing
tchen you'll see our hair a cop bump so
here's the cop this cop is now right
behind the guy also he tries first out
the window then he goes [ __ ] it straight
through his window are you supposed to
do that sure
guess so he didn't hit me he's just
making on top of like what's the best
course a latch it but he didn't hit him
he did he hit kill kill kill oh yeah I
think the other one got hit too it's a
badass
Wow look constantly thinking holy stops
in there holy G loads his magazine
homeboy what's up homeboy muscat yeah
dime yeah so one one guy died another
guy ran up look at that dude yeah kill
him yeah holy [ __ ] yeah crazy was it the
driver died I'm sure I don't know
Kathy was a passenger that's what she
gave Delta back [ __ ] did that
cop is a yes yeah oh my god yeah what
definitely these two thinking yeah so
was the driver that died so he moved to
the passenger seat afterwards Wow later
died at the scene also police say the
suspects fired 34 rounds officers Wow we
have a link Amana fired 31 shots and
imagine being a cop all this [ __ ] you
got a seam in that guy's a badass that
cop yeah I I feel like this [ __ ] I know
it's his job I don't really like he
should be celebrated I agree we don't do
can we so much pain on cops all the time
we see all the mistakes they make but
then how many how much of this do we Wow
exactly they protect way more than they
hurt they do yeah but we don't sell a
picture of you like the Haitian as a
warning day
one of them in the study with outcomes
they put a lot of people to talk about
the movie the purge yeah they protect a
lot of people who are victims of crime
you know crime and I'm sure someone's
out there going this is Savage
right Wow I can accept his own [ __ ]
day like what about a celebrate that I'm
sure he will
you know I don't think before saying
that his his force was commending him on
his bravery and everything that he
[ __ ] in right guys so that guy doc I
they were shooting at him he loved to
close the distance he just closed the
distance he was like now I'm not gonna
stop Wow William Romano mana that's the
cup yeah please don't be here please
don't be a DJ on the side wow that was -
sounds like it's Samoan or something
yeah well my biggest guy from smokin
thick the thick is a DQ blizzard cop at
the top right there homeboy on the right
no no all right move on chin what else
we re still I was a sick video man eat
your heart out cops no joke that guy was
ready the show that's the best shooting
through the windshield Piper's you feel
like it would be like that the bullets
would I don't know I'm sure they're
taught that I'm sure you're taught I'll
shoot through your windshield
man that's crazy
all right I feel like they live for that
[ __ ] too right I tell us been a you
don't sign up for to be a cop just to
write tickets parts you're busy LA yeah
boys want Eames now they've been police
busily am busy business is a-boomin to
history's list so boomers are narrow
it's booming
south central business is allowing
there's a lot of killing going on all
right Chris Leben is facing Phil Baroni
Pilbara your knuckle brah October 20th
and that's Chris Leben signing leave
room in here bare-knuckle boxing
that's stuff that remember that uh
Rebecca Becca that girl with all the
tattoos Oh crawling that's a big
interesting giant hands about 185 did he
yeah
okiyama at 70 the widest face I've ever
seen in my life in person mmm great nice
guy
he'll brawny good guy too yeah they're
gonna punch each other's been a process
old-school dudes man yeah guess leave it
as one top fella another quick one
Tyreese so he was on a podcast with that
guy from TMZ I just saw his name the
black guy from TMZ Oh van laughing the
guy that went I'll find Kanye West you
remember this yeah so he was on the
podcast and I listened to a good chunk
of it and he was completely lucid and
well-spoken and everything goes I regret
everything that happened he said that
when he was going through a rough time
he went to his doctor the doctor gave
him an theis like preference just like
psych meds you know yeah and that's Ari
just messed with his head he he doesn't
remember doing anything like he doesn't
need to remember the whole crying it
makes sense cuz he didn't he seemed to
you don't like yeah yeah and he seems
like a very nice person she was cool
yeah he seems like a sensitive his
videos were outlandish those videos were
ridicu
those meds could do some crazy stuff to
people man so yeah so nice and he's all
good I mean he seemed like he was all
good cuz they asked the rock was on
Bravo with Andy Cohen they go you know
I'll see you and Tyrese had your issues
you know are you guys ever even get back
together up cuz like I have no desire to
speak to him anymore
well but there's no reason we should
talk yeah yeah he was having a manic
episode mm-hmm did you see that beef
jerky
do you see the [ __ ] like did you see
that beef jerky might be linked advice
to the thing beef jerky might be linked
to manic episodes
[ __ ] of it what come on people are
stretching or you just batshit crazy
listen when I was a kid
even this time going to manic episodes
now [ __ ] but beef Jerky's been around
forever
oh yeah but I wonder what's going on
basically the first beat effort they put
salt with how I'm saying oops
I'm gonna be from top its next a mania
cured meat that's what it says 3.5 times
more likely to have a history of eating
cured meat people or interesting or fell
with mania
I mean beef jerky salami and hot dogs
and other processed meat snacks but I
mean we all eat pizzas and stuff like
that all the time you have to [ __ ] your
greats yeah yeah no this is the
exception everything but 3 for 3.5 times
more likely that's pretty impossible I
know why I know Slim Jim ain't happiness
though stephannie Slim Jim
man there's less same stepped in this
little home time me too Jim's gonna ask
nice a lot of beef jerky yeah I still do
yeah that cry think it's crave be true
you the facts the best one that's the
best ones it's so plain with me
Oh crave beef jerky and they have like
they have like the cranberry eaten sour
so sweet and spicy my mouth is watering
for that [ __ ] it's good stuff so you
[ __ ] you and your turkey jerky though
right turkey jerky some ho [ __ ] in it
yeah turkey jerky turkey socks man
there's no flavors I'm turkey some jerky
can be so hard to Oh God
you know I was a kid eat it instead of
letting these two have diff when you go
to check out these have the plastic
container he could open up yeah I got a
big slab a jerky I just chomp on that
they're so tough
I know disgusting I know I must have
ruined my inside terrible terrible free
peoples touch them too and then put them
back in the day that's how cowboys and
everything when you were in the West you
you jerk your meat always me me yeah to
keep it you know through the wintertime
you dirty me man you salt it up dry it
salt it keep it in the Sun try it wheels
your roll up man
I know why do we laugh at jerk you're me
cuz it's stupid
but I think I laugh cuz you were dead
theorists and didn't think anyone would
laugh at you you jerk you're me we gotta
grow up
oh let's do this one Ginny's a relaxing
jerk you know all right so this guy
Sergio Hernandez tight triangle choke
there yeah and I guess the guy that he's
triangle choking is a lot bigger like 50
pounds bigger than him so this guy
Sergio and his dad were going to his
dad's house they found someone in the
backyard which was this guy and the guy
said he go he was he was trying to find
his dog or something and then they found
out that the window was open to his
dad's house so he was a burglar so they
chased him grabbed him brought him back
to the house kept him in a room before
for cops to come by then he tried to
escape again and this is when he
attacked him and got him to the ground
and put him in a triangle choke I guess
he's a professional MMA fighter from San
Diego yeah don't move Annie was
basically everybody every third guy's a
fighter
yeah or marine yeah San Diego's not a
place you wanna pick a fight
oh I took dude when I was at La Jolla
the kind of story you know Jay Buster
always gotta get drinks yeah I'm telling
you guys there's some great people on
here this isn't the place you want to be
after-hours hanging out yeah because
there's a lot of tough guys there's a
lot of testosterone there's a lot of
negative energy yeah I'm gonna wants to
test and J fake how bad can it be
we were pulling out it's like 1:00 in
the morning we're pulling out of the
Comedy Store right we're by our hotel
you know or the hotel where they keep
you there the the condo and it's by all
the bars and there's you know we're at
the crosswalk and they're a little bit
ahead late you know when you pull out a
little bit toward the crosswalk is and
just these bro bros just start banging
on the hood of the car me yeah that's
yeah they're either Marines they're
college kids and they're looking for a
good time but I mean they're drunk and
looking scrap yeah like this isn't a
place it's a bar in San Diego they're
telling me where the Mongols are right
maybe it's the Hells Angels hangout and
Navy SEALs hangout in fact it took place
for me you know what I bet you have zero
problems there probably that's where I
would go yeah you're probably you're not
gonna promise it yeah maybe SEALs don't
want problems health angels definitely
want those problems yeah they don't want
any notoriety they don't want any of
that yeah shine on them the place young
proms is is where it's young your guys
we don't know you frat yeah
you don't want that it's crowded yeah
everyone's [ __ ] sauce Rob tan abs
dicks yeah
with girls yeah there's one hot girl for
seven dudes it's a sausage fest I get I
I told you I don't want to I'm like I'm
telling you don't want to go out here
there's some great places but we're at
in PB Pacific Beach it's I've been here
man he's coming on spring break and we'd
get in fights every time every spring
break we would you know now I'm sure you
guys don't know why I'm they don't give
up you are they don't care man here that
bigger Hells Angels don't give a [ __ ]
bro
well especially got liquid courage yeah
and also but I would never put myself in
that situation because sure they would
of course here's some tough guys out
there yeah they don't care I'm the
street fighter so I should be listening
to shake it done that's the [ __ ]
Queer Eye for the straight guy that's
the guy dresses and skinny jeans and
meet us here at the hall bar where you
did fight when you're growing up though
yeah yeah well now they on specially put
in spring break he would murder
you can fights all the time at their
spring break men all football players
oh yeah how you guys all of us and
almost a Cheyenne Tunes yeah everywhere
we go again fights you ever get arrested
for fighting never when you see giant
dudes man you see giant dudes fight in a
bar and close-up hear their noise good
it's forgot like me I get the [ __ ] away
because it's that force that - like that
thought was that wrong and they're
taking people out with them sit at sit
at a UFC fight winning cage fighting
there's heavy weights in there on TV
it's almost when I was live in Jackman I
was right there with that other 500
pounds of meat yeah moving around the
force is crazy like like I obviously I
know well know that the lopsy Francis
and it closed a bad example but just how
big those men are but I remember being
caged side for when Shane and Brock
Lesnar fight and they're just Almighty
just blonde surfer men and with the cage
the cage moves and then just a jab it's
just this it's just but on TV it's
almost like it's not real to us you know
yeah look when you see saw on TV like it
almost D values what's going on they're
kind of barbaric yeah simulation you
work a side
Shane Carwin and Brock Lesnar yeah
fought that night and then went back one
came trained up and then went back out
there that's nuts
it's a cool moments man yeah you thought
for sure if Shane was gonna win right I
cried so hard man when he lost I cried
so hard and then Shane was on the ground
like hyperventilating that's what I saw
his body like if I just shut down and
then Dana came in I think Lorenzo was
there too and he was everyone out of the
room and like it he's like Shaab you can
stay and then they gave Shaima check as
long how much oh god I feel way better
beers on you I'll see you out there
wow what a Brock may go under Brock
Lesnar yeah
deserves every penny you always talk
about that like Brock is still is still
the draw young close no matter what
freak bigger draw than Daniel bigger
draw and beard Rob and John John's yeah
Wow always always has been Wow
WWE guys in he's legit like the wrestler
to fighter like yeah he's just so huge
to it just people want to tune into that
freak show yeah yeah and it's not a
freak show like CM Punk written
experiment like the [ __ ] and
fight man yeah
I used to can't see talk [ __ ] to him
can't see go after him and go after him
this steel trying to get like you you'd
go after Brock always and people are
like oh you like him now you're talking
[ __ ] around being a fire Mike yet cuz I
was in the game I was trying to get a
fight yeah trying to get the mega fight
yeah if I would beat Big Nog probably to
have that fight really okay what's up
bro come over here come here dude how
dare you not come on our show get over
here now
Bobby Bobby Lee just knocked on our
[ __ ] door Bobby is the best shirts
man last night shirt was fired too bro
what's up first of all don't don't walk
in don't walk in like you know you walk
around like you're on hot coals you you
act all dainty was he gonna be mean bro
and why is your warrior pants a guy came
up to me at The Comedy Store and came
and said you know you're really
important to me and I never forgot what
you said to Bobby when he was on your
podcast and and you said to him you got
to keep going
I'm sorry for the [ __ ] boys Bobby Bobby
Bobby
Bobby's Bobby's jeans Bobby's jeans are
$300 Bobby's Bobby's we're 300 our
[ __ ] ratings bro will do guess bro
you came back from China that's not true
I have a very strong voice yes I do
Bobby thanks my man your podcast
appreciated man have a good night have a
good day guys man they crashed our
podcast don't ever open the door again
for those people Bobby Lee lookin
button-down there's always one of his
buttons is open like just doesn't give a
[ __ ] he's so funny did you did you roll
out of a couch you cut his hair video
game yeah
his beauty games there's a hot girl they
have a podcast he's amazing um funny man
moving on just [ __ ] up our whole show
didn't they great lot of dudes up in
here the real businesses around just so
people know we're in like an office
building yeah and then me and Brian took
this over first podcast ever be in there
then Thiel followed us here and now it's
bit of a [ __ ] show but the rest of the
offices are like real nine-to-fivers
trying to work it out here that's right
that's right
we don't care though okay we live on the
edge on the edge like a couple of
Christian boys don't believe in him you
go to hell I hope you enjoy a lake of
fire forever forever yeah yeah woman
come on your head and your head we got
to pick a religion right now which one
we going with chanting this is I don't
know how to say Muslim well I'm a little
Christianity just easier there's more of
an infrastructure I feel like a Buddhist
Buddhism is good I'm about Buddhism me
too bro I want to I want to observe
myself and release myself of attachment
dude
namaste ah nice day but um no I'm gonna
stay I had a woman come up to me last
night asked me if I'm gonna leave you
gonna leave
namaste doraville I don't want to
consummate this two good-looking women
it's one very young beautiful woman goes
I'm Jesus I just want you to know I love
you of your podcast and I have psoriasis
and I went well you're you're a nine
thank you say we should rub our funny
voice you were a really hot friend and
she goes my mom was can my mom take a
picture of us and I went your mom she
was yeah go your mom she's 40 wanna go
okay mom's 10 years smoke show 10 years
younger than me yeah both of them will
say mil mom and daughter
you're still imported me I was like okay
we'll see you later don't keep your
finger in the cage like that you could
get big get out of here
get out of here 24 year was the story
goin bro just make you feel good
I just think that I'm hot attractive
people told you you're good and I'm a
poster boy for psoriasis now and my
bravery and I just want everybody know
that I feel like you're anti poster boy
for psoriasis because you don't do
anything about it ya know I have so many
people send me like dude I got it I had
it way worse than Bryan I took this it's
gone no I'm good I'm tell me to [ __ ]
get on taking care of it now I'm on it
you quit playing grab a tittie pizza
last night not a good people I think I
know I had for dinner last night
I need all day I need all day and
they're nuts storm like damn I'm
lightheaded and there was a doughnut
I saw that I had it done it and you
thought it was a weekday we're in front
of everyone I'm in conversation my
friends Brian goes no don't eat that
that's a we don't know it oh [ __ ]
and he was already has already gone he
was gone he who's a small blueberry one
I broke my keto diet small [ __ ] taking
giant bites on the home so is my
treatment of so guys so I did I head out
there was a pizza and I was like I have
no room to Jones Jones yeah there's
gonna be three piece of there that's
unblocked they're open till 2:00 or we
have some good news in Chicago yeah yeah
daddy's paying for daddy's pan daddy's
paying for Papa's man daddy pay yeah for
everything we're gonna drink some good
wine with Yoji anima I want real room
service - all right man put your credit
card down bro Papa Papa don't take
advance Papa Bear come on
no I'm not with my town I'm not your
daddy now I don't want my tell us bro no
don't call me Dad yeah I'm not doing my
tell Sally she can do how that I mean
order milk shakes out 2:00 in the
morning you got as many as that won't
stick to your keto nope
I'm off keto for this per Charlie got
chin pretty much other things are kind
of sad so all right you chin and you
know what I don't want the sad ones cuz
I don't want you any more depressed yeah
because you know what you know as our
friend David avez touch of the Black Dog
today got a little touch the black dog
black dog why don't we get a little
kratom in you won't use some kratom why
don't you go to Brian's house and kick
his Corgi mm-hmm
no not mcore ghee never the Corgi
once you put you two green fingers in
that corgis nose Mike or you'll bite you
I wish you would never be that guy so
riled up it's crazy that guy yeah did he
bite people
no but he's just the best dog I've ever
had oh that's so extreme I loved that
dog do that hey I know I should go with
no I don't want you to put him down
gonna work on this no you want to kill
their dog I don't like corgis Bo got
some long arms
what was your reach oh god what was it
was I don't give a [ __ ] wondering oh let
me guess it's [ __ ] here's my Pembroke ah
which one listen that's my dog
but you know what wow that's a Google
starts I've seen your dog do use a melon
lru it's good thing I understand angles
I'll take right I'll take care your core
you though
that's why hey we'll see you this
weekend kids Friday cago get your
[ __ ] dish pizza is ready they'll
fight or the kid are coming at all that
but we're excited you're bad you know
suppose email to be there Joseph's gonna
be there to make grand old time Chin's
gonna be there I'm gonna be there if we
get we forgot the payment structure ah
come on man yes Brian and I earn Chicago
Thursday Friday once yo Thursday two
shows Friday's shooting is special
[ __ ] is August 1st I'm sorry first
weekend in August I met Austin cap
cities all the shows almost sold out
second week I'm in Dallas asked in
improv and then September tickets for
Seattle just went on sale get you some
oh I got a little little news for you
guys
hey Vancouver remember when Brian I
[ __ ] you over and canceled our dates
Vancouver I'm coming in September
one night one theater show really what's
up that's great what's up oh yeah I just
got a lot of energy in the show's ending
why don't you take it out on you maybe
50 grand they're coming open for you
yeah maybe men yeah we've got a pistol
pistol coffee was a revolver I feel like
the revolver
pistol is a great name pistol oh and
then uh the clap with uh roots of fight
and find the kid just dropped today 9:00
a.m.
neverending summer Venice vintage soft
butter soft as the kids call it butter
soft butter South give that roots a
fight and then you can also there's a
link on t5k comput tickets for Brian and
myself t f-- at kake.com I'll see
everyone tonight the comic store Thiel
Vaughn if he doesn't die shooting this
[ __ ] [ __ ] podcast he's doing
right now but we'll be there at the
Comedy Store see guys thanks for coming
out
Brian excited to shoot your special
brother I can't wait buddy it's time so
it's not a circle
they're coming for this baby but we're
gonna kill it it's flying out the nest
gonna steal the show gonna take all your
fans all right this is a farm kid we're
out